this is a panel discussion and followed
by a reception on the occasion of the
publication of the book of natural
vanity democracy is figured I was going
to do that iris it this way Karen cannot
be taught that often it cannot be done
too awful I agree and we are going to
have a presentations from core of our
colleagues and then open in any response
from Nadia and then open it to to the
discussion I will introduce everyone I
want to say that the joint event on with
the Institute of religion culture and
public life the lake in European
Institute and the payment Center for the
Humanities where we're located so a park
or sponsored event we will start with
comments by Vicki burrito so I will
start introducing everyone from that
side on Vicki el marido is a professor
in the Department of Political Science
and the school of international public
affairs here at Columbia University she
is the author of the labor unions
partisan coalition's and market reforms
in Latin America one of her books and
the other one political competition
partisanship and policymaking in the
reform of national anthem
then we have professor there we go in
cooking okay who is an associate
professor of history at The New School
for Social Research and the director of
the Janey program in Latin American
Studies is the author of many books on
fascist the Holocaust and Jewish is to
Latin America you rock his latest book
is called trance and plenty clashes they
went a little bit my supposed to watch
it why can't my jealous probably go well
watch out for what they say to see if
there is the influence of the hide until
next we have maria pia lara with the
professor of philosophy at the
University autónoma metropolitana Mexico
and visiting scholar at the Department
of Philosophy at the new school she is
the author of the disclosure of politics
struggles over the semantics of
secularization and narrative narrating
evil it pushed metaphysical theory of
reflective judgment last but not listed
oh we have actually not yet to sorry iz
iraq heads nelson rather professor of
political science and history of
columbia
university and actually the president
the current president of the sssc here
in New York his most recent books are
here itself the new deal and the origins
of our times which just now last week
water by grant awards so again and then
action was white and unfold history of
racial inequality in 20th century
America and finally again but not least
Nadia or vanity who is the author of our
book and his professor in the Department
of Political Science at Columbia
University here and is the recipient of
the very distinguished a bland fest
faculty award she is the author of many
books representative democracy
principles and genealogy one of them
mill on democracy from a deviant polish
to representative government in addition
to democracy disfigure that we are going
to discuss today I'm going sit in the
background here but I think you each get
ten minutes for comments and then not a
response and then we also need to
convert to discussion welcome everyone
thanks a lot for the invitation although
I'm not by any chance theories and bring
a political scientist and have a chance
of winning fantastic book that I
recommend for one more so I'm going to
talk a little bit from my stunt on WT
from come on empirical as a vertical
american physical society and I thought
that Nadia provides great argument for
the fellows Brazil and democracy as some
of the South America will be valued ease
she emphasized to threats to the more
pressing that might constitute this
gives every democracies that are
particularly important in the Latin
American exploring one is economic
inequality and the second is the
concentration of the media so I'm going
to use these two in trying to make my
comments and based on the experience of
the region the first college like
hardest on political equality uncritical
equal political liberty and this idea
that it requires also positive our
freedom of speech not just negative
freedom of speech and here a point that
I wanted to you know Nadia to comment
more is the two sides and these are two
very polarized sides claimed that they
are defending freedom of speech for
democracy and they were very different
proposals indecently so I want if you
haven't won the second comment is more
on radio communication and I think you
know having the Italian experience under
the stone in your mind most of the
discussion is centered on the media
obviously but I was I was thinking that
you could talk more about the world of
personalized forms of communications of
the world of networks religious and
ethnic parties and neighborhoods and and
networks are very important for for
empirical political science in the study
of American politics network and
fragmented public opinion but there's a
lot of debate that responsiveness is to
this individual citizens that chat with
each other that is not the way you
discuss
individual public opinion but that's not
how we cut this empirically a lot of the
times we chat with your neighbor you
chat with your friends and people for
public opinion but not as a political
action in everyday discussion and that's
not part of the discussion currently and
then also my generate tensions within
individual public of individual opinions
in the sense that you might segregate
yourself it might generate threats of
others by self-select segregation
general polarization we see that in the
Indy American context very much but also
now make politicians responsive certain
groups and not to other so your idea of
majority is you know thinking about the
medium boulder but that's not
politicians are not always responsive to
the medium voltage sometimes I'm
responsive to core about this so how
that talk to your your discussion of
democracy something that we've really
loved to hear about and the other way in
which this personal networks are
important is in in the discussion of
populism salatan Americans have spent a
great deal of time looking at a
population and and I agree with you that
the narrative of population has this
kind of mass imagination but the reality
of populism it's very intelligent so
these networks and different functional
categories really getting to generate a
lot of diversity within the Latin
American populist movements which are
very different from the Europeans you
also want to talk a little bit today to
the different expression so it's true
that polarizations you say polarization
establish identity and generates Muslims
dignity to the mechanism of
representation in the name of there's
one collective affirmation of the wheel
of the letters or the people and bring
this I thought it was fantastic this
again only English people is it secure
and it's true coconut oil gold even it's
always a singular our collective poor
and and it's you know that that brings
the intolerance for the sense
patients with institutions but in the
Latin American experience there is I
think more to it there is a call for
direct democracy for referendums for
recalls for participation even for
multicultural lights if you look at the
current populist experience in the
region they really call from the right
of the indigenous people for the right
even of you know different gender
options and much less than a phobic that
they european version and what did that
in American populace have both in its
classical version earnings in contact
contemporary personal although I am sure
that I come to disagree here in the
legitimacy certainly not based on for
sellers based on outcomes but outcomes
that involve redistribution material and
symbolic redistribution so the
impatience with institution needs to be
understand in the sense of a
polarization against an elite that you
don't want to react so we're trying to
get them before they get at us and put
of the legitimacy that this narrative
encounter is because the other side also
further eyes and I was I was looking at
you noted of course I went back to
thoroughly something fun because I think
like you know made they were reaching of
fairness and that is possible but you
know when a lot they don't got cancer
people right long life to cancer on the
on the street I mean when Karen was
because there was a decree that says any
person who lives in McKees or status of
the deposed dictator and his consort in
public view uses the world such as
perilous Mercer positions and radiation
such as Pyrenees part in a lot but you
know will be sentenced to prison term so
I mean the polarization was on both
sides and the way you know you read the
book you look at polarization from one
side and you don't see the other side in
finding them in the experience and I
think that that aunty the ante lead
component of the Latin American populism
really gets rain for by the elite
reaction to populism and in that says
the
American experience of populism is
different from the European that's more
kind of recognition in Latin America
population is the politics of abundance
in Europe is the qualities of scarcity
we don't have anything to reduce you so
it released with status we redistribute
you know we are whatever is Nyssa to the
nation and i discard the others but i
think that gives us a very different
flavor to the narrative in the book and
I would really want to hear what you
have to shun and anyway we'll return to
that because these are so fine when I
come to say and we know if I am very
high as here speaking as an Estonian
Barroso and experian of those who
generally are against democracy so so
I'm all the time i mean i think is a
fantastic book one move that i write a
book that i really learned from and I'm
of asking all the time these kind of
ready it won't take the conversion what
does it say about dictatorship Aneesa is
a teaser and dirty time in that kind of
in a way combing the book against that
kind of brush really luminous what
democracy is and I think there is a lot
to be said that all of that and that is
I mean something that that I believe is
surprisingly so I would have done to
this point but I wanted to ask you I
mean our dictatorship um that's wait now
I mean they book a foreign historian at
least it provides a an incredible pretty
powerful combination of a critical I
mean critic inferior at fear really
study self-reflective as well as an
intellect on Keith to be of all these
concepts so I really felt that these in
this book I have to say again for my own
narcissistic reasons but also there is
something which is interesting
to me too in a way the cup should
suppose to cover I mean history
understand itself which is this idea of
a democracy procedure and this is
instance on the pursuit and inception
experience of the time in six because
basically we are I mean at least
explicitly we want to say that we are
somehow all the time mediating between
now we're all know something values and
and they only subject of the starter and
yet you insist that they precede the
okra see is in itself are not magic take
or what democracy's so I mean that is
also something that for me open a a lot
of questions regarding means house we as
historians where we approach democracy
so another point that I would like to
make I mean these aren't just any night
sharing we do my impression such a a
separator and paste button and another
thing that I would like to make he said
a the book is really important a
particularly for historians but also
more specifically for against Oakland in
America because of its very powerful and
and no el khatib okay of a systemic
notions of democracy and it specifically
they were cover come bother because it
is that work which is a which is
extremely important as being canonized
and suddenly DC say becomes the norm of
democracy itself and I i have to say
even if i consider myself to be
ambivalent after being your book i am
less ambivalent towards Africa
understanding of democracy because of
course it's an issue of as a citizen now
runners and external faith and you know
I would like to become beings by for
some below but but basically you make I
mean really a very strong case about a
crowd and perhaps leads to I mean
products I would say and was freeing it
that way protect two or more dictatorial
also that again understanding of fee and
something that I wanted to ask is about
this person
the French context of that of that
notion of the people that this all the
time context what I sing and criticize
him but at the same time is
impersonating when he devises this
normally take over I mean what are or
should be the outcomes of democracy and
as he was not and as a fertility a
demonstrates that all the time in a way
leads to disfiguration of for democracy
so for me that was really most
challenging you convincing even I have
to say perhaps I'm up more of a convert
into a procedure you that you put
forward after three bespoke now in terms
of I mean and I'm really poorly mccann
powerful and to me technically
convincing argument is a criticized of
of the tradition of reading populism in
the way than that class what is
important about laclau is not only that
that that he I mean perhaps the
innovation is that he likes it I mean
this normally fail compilation but as
basically preparedness then go straight
home I mean the understanding of
populism that he provides is pretty
conventional and he's rooted in a in a
in a share in a shared takeover popular
series share by people that are against
or all in favor of it so I think into
media was that what that was really
interesting because in a ways bringing
back like cloud to replace that is a
that is a working fruited rather than
buying the argument that that these are
kind of transcendence after the
publication of his book meaning that all
the works on populism on one thing and
now he provides an understanding of a
politic and as such as populism so for
me that was very very important and i
wanted to mention now a disability and
that is fraying in the in the context of
bloggers be figurations of democracy
Valenti understands them and they are in
a listen compasses of course other
aspects of the book that I would just
mentioned in passing which are of course
a place visited in ocean and devastating
notion of democracy I that I've
mentioned before but police interest is
that the probability sachets that one
country and perhaps even integrate with
a fittingly mentions that any practice
or in history these things are much more
are in a constant interplay because I
mean there is a way to relieve a
population in terms of foreign cases
through these politically and notions
and even to some extent it is the vir
claiming that he or she knows a nice an
interesting notion of all democracies so
I mean to me I was sauce already
challenging to I mean I was thinking
again and again come to think about the
cases that I'm entertaining a for my own
than CC sweet reasons which are paid
only paid only so many particular i'm
finally latest issue of the in America
and ideally it would be in terms of the
difference is running in Europe the
understanding of the people ditched us
in afore we are in a way that that in
Latin America last know and in America
the enemy and is much more flexible and
as Assad as intolerant of lauren zima
cities it is very open to accept again
and again those who were enemies but can
be converted into friends so I mean the
notion of the fitness is very perhaps
but it's more open and yet its share
something the populace fruit that you
present them in with the European cases
and one interesting thing is a what is
going on now in Italy or more
specifically in devadiga because I mean
what we have and I think I visa is a up
a notice for a popular person also
explore the table I think that basically
the notion of I mean in my classes are
Yogi's signaled a Vatican as one of the
cases in
in one more political system that is not
that much basically that its legitimacy
through them is cooking them in an older
notion of sovereignty and yet you have
this guy now then to mix mix things up
and somehow provide a sort of
achievement legitimacy that is not only
a loosening the youth divine but now
routinely people um by the way he also
with Cepeda knees I mean he was a melee
champion inning and you know the right
and in warrior yell and scream right
organization in the in the in the 1960s
and 70s and he's been interesting to see
how in a way for policing cos which they
were article and no man sorry no is it
yes so under the question that forecast
I wanted to ask in relation to that it's
always place in children because i won't
thinking about this idea of forming
groups of pink line so professionally
written I'm fine I mean finally it is a
question of focus on fascism I and in
that regard how this relates to
dictatorship my question was about how a
misunderstanding of because placing that
you're one point you said population is
not revolutionary and yet you finish the
chapter on Buddhism by saying that if my
game show regime change that in charity
for totally teri any single or
dictatorship and I wanted to ask you I
mean about that because victory in
itself sir cuz cinelli kosta please
bring Darion notion so for example I
mean a the American dictatorships that I
study the absentee the interest I mean
they're speaking for the people they are
there for the people although they are
not they are knocking in Chile a
Matamata lectra in mathematics that
Nabokov regime steel recomment axes so
anyway I would stop there these are
thinking so
in order to be really asked I always
thought that Italy to people who before
we would explain a little bit about the
book since they haven't explained
anything way of a does the concepts of
the committee selected as well and I
never been at his book called Marcus is
he good democracy is hindered separating
attempt to cope with the problems of
modern and institutional democracies it
is also a welcome critical effort
because he has to consider not only the
conservative views were clearly against
democracy like couch made for example
what's up on those who want to defend
democracy by transforming it from the
start we see that would be not his main
goal is to insist on a very strict
definition of democracy as a tired
voting diary she says we won opinion
wise in particular to representative
democracy a system in which an assembly
of elected representatives rather than
the silly citizens directly is endowed
with a ordinary function of making boxes
on page good boss we might say that she
pursues is pretty college Enda against
those theories who think they can save
democracy by radicalizing it while she
insists but the concept of democracy has
his dire key to remain on top I have
problems with his game but i must say i
don't disagree for diagnosis first why i
agreed that she targets with good reason
post all fours represent flattened ism
and flatten it when she calls those
specialists that supposed to take the
reading government because they know
more is very may become king was first
in the sense that they are the ones
really know
the reality and they can leave the
country with that that's a well-found
way of quality then the populace that my
two previous colleagues have talked
about and the 13 years they play visas
which is really created a lot- today
popular spy but this is about when the
leader what he wants is to have just the
winning passionate acceptance of form of
there is nothing but a theatrical she
calls it is that it get a sort of
representation in the empower of the
salt so I think there must be so I agree
with this that these are three really
spectacular problems for democracy but I
think there must be room for nuances
enemies if important focus on empirical
examples I'm glad my two previous
colleagues have dedicated law to Latin
America but Europe in fact is when seems
to me really the worrying diagram of
Nadia's concerns and you see why Jackie
Mason it seems to me has been the
hallmark of the political property of
the European Union this project was
built by experts lost personal
professional politicians and right into
a big faith on the one side the
institution the European discourse did
not connect the local citizens on the
other hand the citizens skepticism
against the idea of the United you are
did not allow them to conceive
consents out of the post Australian
notion of the nation states in the past
the interactive world was constructed by
served by the social movements and their
experiences for the two world wars we're
at the back of these efforts in the 17th
the disappearance of the buffer state
came along with the capitulation will be
uncivil Scots the authentic conceptual
and political conservative revolution
was owned by margaret thatcher and
ronald regan in the united states both
destroyed the structure of arrears at
the local state for capitalism to roll
without borders in the same manner the
politicians of the left stop seeing
themselves as an alternative to
conservative governments and focus more
on how to stay in power so a problem for
me are the factors of the left not the
office of the left and they were
successful the more they move their
positions to follow and even more
radical Lee conservative political
agenda it was you to this efforts that
the name of globalization we claim NT
final momentum the deregulation of the
capital the flocks of it and the
ideological consensus of neoliberal
theories were the grounds of the actual
Europe this was the plutonic case where
experience were called technocrats were
elected and philosophers wrote about
cosmopolitan about the midst of
capitalism being the source of Liberty
and the consumer as being the new
autonomous being where the results of
these events the economical crisis of
2007's respective the new social
movements have not been able to
articulate a political agenda with
concrete goals in institutional and
democratic terms in other great
citizenship even though they are
entirely justified has not been
translating
here in men emancipation and justice as
related to the Moffs the cosmopolitan
momentum failed because he could not
generate a practical ways in which to
construct a collective imaginary with a
progressive you something like the one
that articulated the reconstruction of
the European countries after the second
war because the deficit in progressive
gear is underwriting practice of the
liberal institutions that are that we
are confronting now is it with a new
kind of social actors who profoundly
reset the consequences of the
destruction of the world for state just
as they are against their regulation of
the market furthermore they also
recently a lack of representation from
the political elites the Qin sequences
the consequences of all of these
problems are that this society have
fallen prey to populist leaders like in
the Netherlands they have massively
Jones themselves to renewables of
immigration and generosity like the
example of the tapes Italian Switzerland
England France and Italy they lack the
capacity into elected government that in
Belgium and they have fallen fallen back
to the worst kind of corruption a
political prime minister and actor in
Italy infant about all criticism and
heat it completely the opposition where
is the left in all this looking at this
devastating landscape one can only see
why you do not is more exceed with
what's going on in Europe unfortunately
those platanus populist temple visit
thinkers are only the proves that what
is at stake here is a crisis of the
concept of
education all together it might lead to
less to the airport of this series but
to a lot of negativity falls from
political actors from the left and the
terrible on westerns sex of the world
dental facilities the cases of Latin
American countries are very different
sort of elements folks that have already
mentioned golly first many countries
there have software terribly sorry
depression modern murders and oppression
very often the institution of church and
the military's work together each
country has its own problems by 1989
however your poor Italian government's
or self depleted and democracies
appealed to go became the political
scenario there contrary to the Europeans
were disenchanted with democracy the
Latin American soul democracy as the new
horizon of expectations their arrival to
this stage with no clear nor was it
intentional terrible contradictions and
even reach Agra historical moments it is
true that here the blackness are not a
strong group even though at some point
they wanted to it but the populists and
the play bc tiring is on we cannot put
them all in one bag since each country
has been something and they they their
struggles against they have struggled
against the specific problems argentina
argentina has little similarities
venezuela and brazil is not like you one
must consider however that in many of
these countries racism is one most
difficult legacies from criminalization
and very often gasps and race are
aligned therefore the populism brought
the possibility to make visible both
were invisible for centuries this might
be the biggest success Chinese
government though it is clear that it
has produced
other problems but I work very well
described by an idea this effect in
Bolivia Ecuador Peru and Venezuela I've
made public sphere an important site
from visibility these groups have an
alternative ideas about democracy and
they might be different than the ones
that even not yet completely sometimes
they might seem to be reflecting the
social imaginary of the nation state
that and also wrote about but often more
often than not they also have shown more
imaginative local perspectives and their
political agendas have been to define in
the populous regions of Morales team on
yourself or chance remember that moment
of them are self coming out and saying
all of these problems you want to
discuss them then let's get together and
discuss last one cannot ignore the
problems of corruption the antagonisms
that erode morality or the prestige of
jihl ism from this perspective the two
most conservative projects Mexico
Colombia are the ones that are fun in
the world situation but they are not
hopeless for some time and this is
something we should consider the problem
there is called a colombia is at least a
democratic country one x equals far
working one the histories of latin
america park with trying to decide wait
princes it easy many of those countries
have operate area pass and some even
genocide the words in other side of
country for Russian and Marco politics
of eroded Democratic pools of citizens
in spite of all these problems the
political agenda the air is framed under
the expectations that are provided by
the term democracy the governments of
those countries have been opposed to
practice groups and the IMF this kind of
examples are opening up to new social
imaginaries what is reality suggest is
that it is not possible to consider all
these iterations named political
concepts are sites of struggles the
market is a concept has not its own
history but histories I was on the
stages of these millionaires be included
in our pressing or understanding of
return a snuff movie 90 often shows the
turn democracy has acquired different
meanings since it comes concept of
popular sovereignty first appeal this
space of opinion was also the one that
about political are due to see
themselves as being capable of doing
something more than just amazing after
printer reach the critical consideration
to the bag here then it would be if we
could stick to the time to figure out
the teenager that would be naevus
concept of democracy house proposes from
her book that example psychic even one
can almost say that it will not remain
in contesting the European political
actors do not see themselves worthy
presented in their democracies when
Latin American populace governments but
even this ability to do social actors
but have not sought the pursuit of pure
reason and antagonisms I rather think
that asuka now PR use almost at the end
of you democracy since it has no utopia
to the leader please the space will
complete even in its definition for
concepts
if you knew me in this definition would
be an never ending story or concepts are
also vehicle size analysis i propose
rice pivots on the idea of democracy as
a government by means of opinion it's
probably the single most important
sentence in the book in particular I
shall explain it relies on the premise
that representative democracy is a die
ARCIC system in which will by which I
mean the right to vote and the
procedures and institutions that
regulate the making of authoritative
decisions and opinion by which I mean
the extra institutional domain of
political opinions influence and each
other each other and cooperate without
merging now that is not just a
definition of democracy it is a
normative statement that is defended
against three disfigurements in this
book and the three disfigurements are
not empirical firms on quite equal
planes but they all have theoretical
underpinnings one of them is a kind of a
political deliberation a fascination
with a bypassing of the plurality of
opinion and bypassing ordinary
procedures in favor of creating zones of
deliberation above and beyond politics
the second disfigurement of treated in
this book is the disfigurement of
populism about what we've heard a lot
the disfigurement is Nadia's word it's
not precisely agreed on by the by
colleagues but it is an attempt to
construct the people a unitary the
people it's a strong version of popular
sovereignty of a very specific kind
which erases of all kinds of degrees of
heterogeneity tension and
disagreement within a populace and
whether it empirically that happens is
another question but that's how it's
presented and the third disfigurement is
that of a pleb dissent arianism which
means not just palomba sites as in kent
state of california voting but it means
a particular kind of leadership
structure associated with the mass that
seeks through various passions as if it
said to mobilize up people to follow a
leader and thus transcend the messiness
of ordinary democratic politics and this
is a picture which might be seen as one
of antinomies a story of the and the
first of each enemy is the bad and the
second is the good the unitary people or
the people as an audience as in the
pleasant Arian version versus citizens
of true the idea that you could discover
a singular truth as in some forms of
deliberation versus a process where the
truths are always provisionally that's
the good the bad is objective interests
the good is shared preferences the bad
is intolerance the goodest tolerance the
bad is order the good is messiness the
bad is cynicism the good is trust and
Trust not a general but trust of
institutions and to this portrait um by
the way with the footnote i should say
every page is full of gems if you want
to read about a critical account of how
her nest ola cloud deals with Gramsci
read it if you want to distinguish
populism from social movements read this
book it's full of such games but the
core of it is democracy and it's
disfigurements in these antinomies and
to this in the Passover season I posed
for the
the first question um on the good side
of the ledger a world of citizens
process of shared preferences tolerance
and Trust of institutions where
empirically do we see such democracy
operating where do we find the
instrumentalities on the that side of
the ledger of empirically factually and
even historically operating in the way
that you will normatively desired not
yet and I don't mean to say it never
does I the empirical question is not
simply where and when do we see such
democracy of work but what are the
conditions that would make it possible
for your a normative world in which
opinion and procedures interact in this
recurrent and a provisional manner um to
continue to be reproduced a second
question also empirical I find myself
wanting to stop reading about at some
point about Schmidt or laclau or rose
and alone or other people who were well
worth spending time with and and to
wrestle with empirical instantiations of
the three disfigurements um empirically
I could think a lot more about a pledget
arianism and populism about the
deliberative mo the deliberative mode
seems to me be you know I'm a dear
colleague like Jim Fishkin invites the
events deliberative assemblies but where
in the world do we actually have a kind
of what Jenny man screwed
called a friendship model at the
liberation actually occurring small town
New England or in the Mansbridge example
of her wonderful book Beyond adversary
democracy a a rape counseling group in
Boston but in terms of the big qualities
of the disfigurement of deliberation
seems to me to be more in the
imagination of political theorists than
in the world that's the question we can
talk I'd love to know and talk about
that but where do we find it and under
what conditions and populism of which
instantiations of our disfigurements of
democracy and which instantiation czar
not democracy at all um that is when do
we cross the border and the same
especially with the premise of Terry on
instance I was trying to think or friday
and I fail to think it's my failure to
think of instances that you'd label a
gusset area that don't cross the
boundary of democracy that move outside
of it or at least certainly outside of
your definition of what democracy is so
is there some kind of zone the liminal
zone that is not quite democratic and
not quite anti-democratic in which these
three disfigurements curve and in that
sense is a democracy disfigured up or as
a democracy who transcended opposed
rejected of consultant third question um
if if we have these disfigurements of
what combinations of structures and
experiences are most likely to fashion
it what is the is there a causal story
that is possible to tell what economic
or social or
fuller institutional conditions change
the probabilities that with respect to
the existence of these three
disfigurements of democracies they're
presented with uncommon depth and
richness riveting richness in terms of
the structures of these disfigurements
and their relationship to keith's
thinkers who instantiate or represent
them but there's less about the causal
conditions that would make one or
another appear and appear in different
ways and different in different places
what is why is there a shift in the
dispositions of thinkers leaders
citizens in a democracy in settled
democracies that in which opinion and
institutions interact why is there a
shift in dispositions toward a clever
setaria mysm toward populism toward of
deliberation and further just a footnote
to that third question is it is there
something about democracy and its
anxieties today as opposed to some other
period that distinctively points in
those directions or are there moments
historical moments for cycles like the
interwar period of the 20th century and
the present that you wish to tell us of
homologous qualities of that lead to
these dangers for democracy and the
final question is how would you like
your readers to think about the
relationship with your analysis to a
literature which I don't think is
present here but is the kind of mid 20th
century empirical behavioral literature
on American democracy and I thought of
one book in particular David Truman's
governmental process
how many people have read the heyday of
pluralist analysis and what does David
Truman tell us he tells us that
interests are subjective and not
objective that there's no such thing as
a unitary public interest that what
really counts and democracy are the
rules of the game not a particular
substantive truth outcome and what
matters is that we be aware that any
politics can experience what he called
in a very dramatic language more
difficult x sic politics um and you you
give three examples of sickness in
democracy is this David Truman revisited
the poor form of a democratic nearest of
the early 21st century and one last
example of a person whom you wouldn't
ordinarily I don't ordinarily think of
as a democratic theorists though
incredibly smart person the late samuel
huntington whose book on political order
and changing societies had a famous set
of relationships and one of the key was
the the numerator in a and a denominator
the numerator was participation the
denominator was institutionalization and
he argued that when participation
populace participation flexitarian
participation outrun thick
institutionalization you get disorder
and he wanted it wasn't he was a
theorist of stability not a theorist of
democracy but the logic of your
presentation and the logic of
huntington's seemed to me to have a
great deal in common and this is not
this is nothing this is not a criticism
um I think that that ratio of
participation institutionalization
with many purposes not just Huntington's
including positively the purpose of
deepening and reviving and instantiating
democratic theory which is the purpose
of this book I was not Sam Huntington's
purpose but the logic of the
relationship of participation and
institutionalization struck me as a
close just as the relationship to the
work of David Truman seemed close and
this would be counterintuitive for a
radical work for the Democratic
theorists and I was curious to know how
you thought about that and so I stopped
asking myself what's happened here can
we help to be an instrument in theory or
democracy theoretical point of using
office at least to interpret this change
in this new reality we know the
democracy is a reason than that and we
have a yes or no position it is
amorphous or not but what if democracy
internally changes how can we look how
can we recognize it how what kind of
names we can define we can use in order
to define it so now I resorted has in
politics a fantastic definition of
democracies which is not a definition is
it is it a picture of the office thing
it doesn't leave from the Commission in
fact is it a picture naked picture
indeed of democracy that start from a
moment of constitutional definitely
Constitution an entity called quality
which is what we have basically and then
it goes through an analysis because of
the social transformation tracks
organizational changes in publish meant
or a strong class division that emerges
so then this democracy has different
internal variations from the
constitutional down to the demagogic are
people in poverty so after that is
another story after that you ever the
tutorial system that is a coalition of
baby price and politically for immunity
and so on so forth so this is the entire
spectrum and within this invite spectra
you recognize this is democracy although
is multiplicity although Easter
vegetarian although is based on experts
today the idea of using politics in
order to reach through say so
fashionable same it's not it's not
marginal is a real issue the question of
impeding competence through political
procedures as if procedures are defined
or design longer to the chain of them so
i would like that is a basic one so how
can i I with that how to solve this so
you need to perhaps to define or 12 this
basic definition of the most basic basic
feature of this body for democracy with
their contour the controls that are not
so thick otherwise all these
distinctions disappear or there's
something else there another regime so
but you there inside of this big
decision because these elections because
they use the press because they use
Kingdom sent to jail people not at least
not now they don't spend them from the
fabric speed although they manipulate
their boss so that they both are
completely impossible to hear or they
are affirmed in a different discretional
way so Steve is democracy so it so this
democracy is this dire key design fee
for me is an important safa quality it's
just certain you can recognize it
involve you recognizing that you can be
recognized
it's not something i don't even better
anything harbour ma says beautifully
defined in a real way even though we did
perhaps too many words but is very clear
looking except from it this duel moment
now this equilibrium which is the 12
moment is the most difficult stuff and
in some sense democracy is like a work
of art because is it firm Alisa tend to
be balanced in tune with the fantastic
ability is the only system perhaps a
democracy that is able to do so in
apparent attempt to redefine is this
relationship between institutions a
rules and between what is outside which
is as pricing different way from
movements to pass these Totino's in a
pluralistic way now what's happening
today according to me is not the
relevance of the institutional side
which more or less really is the same
you can have a presidential system
versus the fundamental assisted but
above all is the same according to me
all the transformations that very
problematic one sometimes this emerges
in the other side of the story they will
obtain information of the information
because it is the first chapter because
one the introduction of private money in
public organization of of information so
the question public market I demands on
5 money and class organization it is
much stronger now the vastly increase of
the qualities in economic and social
life and does the potential for some
citizens to have much more in organized
more than other citizens is an issue we
cannot escape from that is something
that is going to change the romantically
our democracies I don't know in which
way but he's an elf at now until now and
this is best and answer to the question
by week at the beginning until now we
ever sold after freedom speech in a
negative sense is enough it was enough
because freedom of speech has to the
negative rights against power as dean
the quintessential family moment of
creation of constitutionality fight the
question is that speech place power
because creates an evil that creates
asian-influenced institutions through
presentations or support and today these
power is an object of and flirting a
regulation and create an acquisition by
some who has who has more economic power
than other this is clear it's evident
you wherever you go so that our
democracy is changing it's precisely
perhaps a democracy in which people are
witnessing our signature and watching a
spectacle that somebody is playing the
question of the public as a I a big I
that analyzes and seeing and judges and
enjoys and you know that this is a new
notion of citizenship that is going to
change because of the change in the
world of opinion and so this is for me
it's a is thus a component I I wanted to
down in order to unite of that I try to
see how this opinion in the world of
opinion change can produce different
outcome one is they missed anyone let's
say meet one it's a depressed is not
only theoretical because there is the
sense that the democracies Parliament's
assemblies are not good enough anymore
to make quick fast competent decisions
we want experts we want because
procedures are supposed
make us solving problems and you know a
technician's is much better to soviet
ruble in generous detail of engine
asleep at case then an ordinary citizen
so oh dear citizens are shut down from
all of concern from these epistemic
necessarily and unfortunately leading
the field of democracy there is this
germ of an aesthetic epistemic deviation
so one may ask you one may ask even and
this would be a topic for a larger book
or a larger search can we have a
democratic theory I think he says it's a
real question democracy's a practice to
make it into a two-tier it may create
something to me in this case at least so
I become more and more skeptical on
these precisely because this a beast and
gluttonous attempt to manipulate the
notion of opinion transfer the European
into question truth and force it's
something that takes away from us what
we had because opinion is a sign of
Liberty the design of societal or legal
frame of participation whatever whatever
you whatever we think and we want and
without any kind of coercive imposition
of research so this is very good is the
opposite edge to do with politics and
with political freedoms nothing else
nothing else democracy doesn't promise
us no eternal life no utopia know a
better society not even a kind of good
decisions because it's not possible to
do that democracy promises ask that
different as we are in many things
sometimes even unequal as we are we are
nonetheless even in our same in the
public as citizens so that that is for
me they struck the strength of these of
this idea otherwise it's a a system not
necessarily well-functioning it produces
bad decisions sometimes the laws are
unbearable how is possible to a blow
that you know they are so and adjustable
for menu
st there are decisions made so the
decision the outcome sometimes it's very
bad it's an effective unethical so this
is it's not here that is precisely in
their neck kappa sonic reality that
allows us to be FBI without any kind of
protection is pretensions to be
something else or better or even in the
tube side of the story so the other two
questions I guess it's a long story but
I don't want to abuse more than that
populism entry visitor is in the king
the other signs are an attempt to square
this year full of dire key another sense
not because they eliminate the opinion
by transforming into a truth exercise
but because they use it in order to
impose that opinion in the wheel that is
inside of the institution now it's
difficult to say what is positive we
know that is a is a is a challenge is
impossible to theorize it because it is
so based on experience on how
sovereignty was constructed your
specific country how it was a massive
how the emancipation from colonization
was created by military or not by the
former all forms of revolutions for a
kind of other forms of emancipation so
populism is not easily treatable as a
category because it is based on contest
the fact is very much so what we wanted
to do is to give some lines some general
categories that you know they return
sometimes and of course my mind that was
not in a little America I to say it was
in Europe where the transformation of a
cell phone beeps population is alien
fact this is not the question of friends
only is a real problem for the entire so
fabulous is there as a permanent
possibility because democracy was
constructed over nation-states in that
over the question of the people as a
nation or using other people is simply
political cat or a legal category but
they admitted so this there
a finally privacy terrorism which seems
to be something more for us because
felicitated at the beginning of the 19th
20th century josh is navin for now there
is a new this new form of militarism is
visible because because empty squares it
will see it outside in the outdoor
square sell anything people have no
longer in despair actually the public is
completely X in some sense and yet there
is two media's the division either
internet because these niches of
identification of quazel movements or
pass to the next through the internet
our new phone also they help technical
to place in this form oh let me see said
an identification so decent is a new
form of place that passes through the
dismantling of intermittent bodies think
about the disappearance of parties of
the different parties and then the media
says institutions or attentive and
generous institutions we do everything
by ourselves without any kind of
certification valve news about so there
is this kind of specialization of
creation opinion on the one hand and on
the other hand a identification between
the people and the leaders in a new way
that is perhaps a visual and more than
active in each square as we used to be
so I don't know whether answer all your
questions little bit but anyway and I
mean either from
you